-Jeff Gordon, I always love seeing you, bud.
-I love seeing you. It's been too long, though.
-It's been too -- -Why has it been so long?
-I know. I want you to come on more than once a year, yeah.
-I love hanging out with you. We have good times.
-I mean, this is crazy. 75 years of NASCAR.
-Yes. -That's wild.
-What's really wild is I remember 50.
You know, I won the championship back in --
I think it was in '98, when they celebrated their 50th
and won the championship that year.
And here we are 25 years later doing 75.
-I have a photo of you from 1992.
Atlanta Motor Speedway.
-Oh, I don't know if I want to see that.
-Well, you got to look at the m--
Look at this mustache. I mean, look at that.
Look at that. [ Cheers and applause ]
That's -- That's what I'm talking about.
-Hey, if you wanted to be a NASCAR driver in the '90s,
that's the way you had to look.
[ Laughter ] -Really?
-No. -No. No.
But I heard there's a little strategy to this mustache.
-Well, you have to understand.
I started racing at a very young age.
I think I was growing a mustache at, like, 12 years old
for the first time, and I was racing against
all these older guys, and I wanted to feel like I fit in
and, you know, look older.
It didn't make -- It didn't work, but I tried.
-No, you look like an actual baby here with a mustache.
-But you have to understand.
Richard Petty, Dale Earnhardt, Dale Jarrett.
I mean, all the greats had mustaches,
so I thought I needed one. -Yeah.
-Luckily it didn't last but another year.
-Do you remember your first race?
-Um, absolutely because, one, it was memorable
because I backed into the wall at about lap 50.
-Geez.
-But it was Richard Petty's final race.
You know, how many people can say
they got to race against The King?
-But this is -- You brought me, actually --
-Yes, we did. -Look at this.
-Well, we've got to celebrate 75 years of NASCAR.
-Look at that. I love this right here.
And you signed it for me, too.
-Well, I mean, you know, we're --
[ Cheers and applause ] Absolutely.
-Do you ever get tempted to get behind the wheel and go,
"I'm gonna show these guys how it's done"?
-No. I mean, I -- I know how hard it is
to get back in there and compete at that level.
But I still love to drive fast.
I mean, I get in a -- I actually did a race,
a sports-car race this last year,
and it did remind me how hard you have to work
'cause I got beat pretty bad, but -- but I love it.
I just love getting in the car,
and just the fun of it is what got me into racing.
And I just don't want to do the high-level competition.
-How are you in the car, like, going to the mall or something?
[ Laughter ]
-I feel like I'm an excellent driver.
I mean, I've got to say -- you know, I don't have any --
-Are you -- Are you left-lane guy all the way?
-I'm left lane if I'm passing.
I mean, you don't belong in the left lane
unless you're doing something. [ Cheers and applause ]
-Wow! That's getting a standing ovation right now.
Thank you for saying that.
-Yes. -Yes.
-I mean, I don't always hang in the left lane.
If I'm not in a hurry, I'll go in the middle lane,
I'll go in the right lane. -Yeah, yeah.
Alright, alright, good. 75th --
-But let's be honest. I'm more in the left lane.
-You're left lane. Yeah, alright.
I figured. Alright, good. You don't lie to me, yeah.
What do we have to expect this season --
February, 75 years of NASCAR?
-What I love about this year is there's several events
that are going to be happening
that I think are going to really sum up 75 years.
Because, first of all, we kick off the season
in a stadium.
L.A. Coliseum is where we start this season off.
We did it last year, but we're going to do it again.
And it's just amazing to see the entertainment
and the racing that close up in this tiny arena.
-Yeah. -And then we're going to go to
a street-course race for the first time in history of NASCAR.
-Talk to me about that. -Chicago.
Yeah, downtown Chicago. Right on the streets.
I mean, they're going to set up a street course.
We've seen other forms of motorsports do it,
but never big, heavy stock cars, loud, roaring stock cars.
-Yeah!
-It's going to be pretty amazing.
I can't wait to see how that turns out.
Plus, it's going to be a festival.
There's going to be music and parties.
So it should be really cool.
And then we're going to do a throwback,
where we're going to go back to North Wilkesboro,
which has not -- I don't think there's been a race there
in, like, 25 or 30 years.
So it's incredible that we're, you know, going to --
And we've got such young talent that's out there.
So it's exciting. -What do you tell
the young talent when they ask you for advice?
Do you go like, "Ugh.
First of all, let me show you how to do it"?
Or do you just -- -No.
No, you know, these guys are in the car every weekend.
I mean, they know what they need.
To me, it's all about, you know, trying to help them
have the guidance or the resources
or just connecting people, you know?
It's a people business. It's all about teamwork.
It's all about the people you work with
and making sure that they have confidence in you
and you have confidence in them.
Of course, there's the branding, the marketing.
I think I could probably work more with them
on that side of it, of the experience that I've had
over the years, more so than I could probably do
anything for them on the track.
You know, I've not been in a car in seven, eight years.
-But, still, you're Jeff Gordon.
Come on, buddy. Like, come on, yeah.
-I mean, if we go to Martinsville, now, maybe.
-Yeah! That's what I'm talking about! Yeah!
You're one of the best ever to do it, bud.
Always good to see you. You know I love you, bud.
Jeff Gordon. -Thank you.
-Check out the 75th anniversary season
of NASCAR beginning February 5th.
We'll be right back with Lauren London.
Stick around, everybody.